Right, this is going to be a slightly more improvised
video than normal, for two reasons.
Er, one, it is really cold here
and I want to move on,
but also because I didn’t know I was
going to be passing through Schengen,
a little town in Luxembourg on the borders
with France and Germany, until today.
But here I am, next to the
international border, the Moselle River,
and that border is a little bit weird.
And I wasn’t going to do another video about
a weird border. Because I’ve done that.
Years ago I went to the towns of
Baarle-Nassau and Baarle-Hertog
in Belgium and the Netherlands,
where the borders are incredibly complicated
and twisted thanks to history.
But that’s an old video that
I’m not really proud of,
and frankly it’s not that interesting:
I only managed about a minute of script
before I had to go into a diversion on sovereignty
and why we even have borders
in the first place.
Strange borders often make
for great video titles,
but there’s not much to talk about
other than “huh, that’s weird”.
Which is also why I’ve never been to the island
that changes country every six months
between France and Spain.
Because once you’re there, what is
there to say but, “huh, that’s weird”.
But it turns out this border
raises a different question.
If you look on the map, there is a tripoint
just of there, to the west of an island:
that’s where France, Germany and Luxembourg
all meet.
It was here – actually, on a boat out at
that tripoint,
where the Schengen agreement was signed,
where most of the countries of the EU,
all the ones that have their flags here,
decided to open their internal borders.
But that the tripoint there
is not strictly true.
The border between Germany and Luxembourg
doesn’t follow the Moselle river:
the border is the Moselle river.
And that’s an important distinction.
In most cases, international borders that
follow rivers
are defined as following the centre line,
which raises questions in itself,
because rivers can erode the banks and change
paths sometimes,
but borders are, at least, usually defined
as a line of theoretically zero width.
Which is how mapmakers mark it.
But here, Germany and Luxembourg share the
river north of France. It is a "condominium".
Under the treaties they signed,
they both have full control over it.
Which means that if you’re standing on the
north tip of that island,
or on that bridge up there,
you are in both countries at the same time.
Not just in terms of
having a foot on each side,
although that may well be
how the locals treat it,
and that’s certainly how
the signs mark it.
But no: standing on that bridge
above the water,
all of you is in both countries simultaneously.
This international border is a shape,
not a line. It’s two-dimensional.
Although, actually, I guess it’s
three-dimensional if you count depth.
Half an hour of research, and I can’t tell you
why they made that decision,
or what the legal result would be if you tried
to commit a crime
on that bridge or on a boat on the river.
I even asked the folks at the little
European museum just over there,
and they didn’t know the answer.
Although they do have a lovely little display
of all the border guard hats
that the Schengen agreement made obsolete.
I suspect that the answer would be
“treat it as if it’s a line, it’s easier”.
And that’s what I mean when I say that there’s
not much to talk about here.
Because that’s one of the wonderful things
about borders like this:
when you can walk between three countries
as easily as you can walk between
counties or towns or neighbourhoods:
it’s a lot easier to say “huh, that’s weird”
and just get on with your life.